good morning Rick how are you Dan I'll
be there with your crew well I've got
Fritzi at home McLovin at home seating
at home Paulie is here in the man cave
and we have a couple other people behind
the scenes and making this possible how
about you we are thrilled that you're
making it possible my crew is getting a
little testy but we've never had this
kind of family dammit you're gonna enjoy
my company I think there's no longer a
question exactly I know you have a song
for us I'll get to that in a moment can
you give us a hint on what the song is
about well it's about what we're all
going through and we're just going to
try to give everybody some semblance of
how to survive
in this era of quarantine also you have
a coronavirus song we call it quarantine
one gene a quarantine yes exactly
all right we've got we've got the Von
Trapp Family Singers here ready to go
all right
let me talk a little bit of football
because you know as much about
quarterbacks as anybody and I I'm
curious are you still all in on Joe
Burrell number one to the Bengals Owen
Napolitan no reason to deviate from that
the kid was fantastic and he did it as
much with his mind is with his body I
know there are going to be people to
pick apart his arm strength and things
that that maybe he's not as physically
menacing as some of the other
quarterbacks that have gone on to
greatness but this guy can flat do it
and I think the Bengals are going to be
thrilled to have him if you're the
Dolphins and you love Joe burrow which
that's Todd McShea says there's no doubt
there's no question they love Joe burrow
and you have the picks how valuable is
Jill burrow if you're the Dolphins what
would you be willing to give up if
you're the GM well there's no question
that he's worth the price the question
is how far do you have the distance
between burrow and to Otunga by llola
because if you like both those kids you
can get I think Tunga by law for a much
less lesser price then you can get
burro just by going up to the third spot
there and getting Detroit's pick I know
that Redskins are going to try to you
know dance around and make people think
that they're interested in a quarterback
but I think they're got they've got to
go taste young and and give Dewayne
Haskins a chance they went and got Kyle
Allen from Carolina to ease the pressure
on Haskins but I think the price for
Burrell going to one will be too
expensive and it's too risky for the
Bengals especially with an Ohio kid in
jobber I think the Bengals have to go
with Berle I think the action will start
then that three and four spot with the
Lions ticks and the Giants picks do you
think the Dolphins go up to make sure
they get to it they have to they won't
get anybody at five I think
Herbert and two will go at three and
four really I think I think you have to
go there you can't risk unless you're in
love with Jordan love no pun intended
unless you're too high though in it Rick
I agree I agree I don't trust that guy
through 17 interceptions in his last
year when he's supposed to be even more
mature and more experienced and so forth
so I I think you have to go I think the
the catbird seats are the Lions and the
Giants though those those are going to
be quarterbacks taken two three and four
in my mind you sold on Justin Herbert I
am you know that guy is a big-time
Talent there's some small ball stuff
that he has to work on meaning that he's
got to be natural throwing the ball out
into the flat - a running back he's got
to be able to drop it off to a swing
route and be able to control what's
howitzer of a throwing arm but he's
brilliant he had the highest grade point
I mean he won the academic Heisman he
stayed for four years in the troop ran
for three touchdowns in the in the Rose
Bowl a year ago I was watching him
against Stanford he was 25 at 27 and
regulation I think the guy has
everything and he's the one guy while we
sit and talk about the quarterbacks that
didn't have the bevy of just brilliant
wide receivers we're not talking about
any his wide receivers
in first rounders so and he lost his
tight end midway through the season his
kind of security blanket so I think this
guy's the real deal but that's when
we're talking to Rick Neuheisel former
college coach and a great college
football analyst for CBS that's and I've
spoken to a few NFL and college people
in a scout as well how hard is it to
assess just how great to and burrow are
given that they have first-round talent
at wide receiver and multiple
first-round talented wide receiver
that's the $64,000 question because
these guys had every weapon known to man
at their disposal I mean they really did
the yards after catch four they used two
teams and these two quarterbacks are off
the charts but I I lean towards burrow
here because burrow was given so much
more autonomy at the line of scrimmage
from Ensminger and Joe Brady and they
gave him the keys to the castle he was
allowed to change run to pass pass to
run he was allowed change protections I
just think his mind is that further
along not that it's superior because I
don't think they asked that much of Toa
given the RPO nature of their offense
but I I just believe that burrow is the
most ready for NFL play quarterback
we've seen in recent memory could you
fix Jameis Winston yet Jameis has to
want to be fixed Jameis has every throw
Jameis has every ability to play this
game at the highest highest level we saw
that over the time in college and
certainly some of the time here in the
NFL what he has shown the inability to
do is learn from previous mistakes you
know an interception is okay if we don't
do it again
but to do it over and over again as he
has done with the numbers shows that
he's not taking the coaching as to what
to steer clear from and and to me and
you look at his off-field personality it
kind of shows the same thing
he hasn't necessarily realize
that some of the stuff he's done before
is beyond sophomoric right you you have
to be able to go to the next level if he
takes the next step and says coach me
coax me a little harder and I'm going to
respond to it then there's no question I
think he can be fixed before we get to
your song if you were gonna take a risk
or take a chance on Cam Newton Jameis
Winston or Andy Dalton who are you
signing up for I go Jameson that in that
you know listen Andy Dalton is a safe
road right it's like the paved road
you're not going potholes and all that
stuff I'm not sure what the upside is
and I'd given where he is in age I'm not
sure how long he lasts cam to me is that
was it was a beautiful beautiful player
but when the legs go so does the whole
product because the legs force teams
into different fronts eight-man fronts
you got single high all of a sudden he
was a great thrower but you needed his
legs to complete the package I'm not
sure given the beating up that he's
taking over the course of his career
he's at that point so Jameis to me would
be the guy that I would lean on but it
would take a long conversation and
understanding that we have to get better
with these mistakes that have plagued
this career coronavirus has an impact on
college football coaches worried about
the schedules being able to start the
off season workouts get ready for the
season do you think there's a date that
would make you nervous if you're a
college coach of trying to get your team
ready and having a full college season
schedule you know in the other thing
that they're worried about having talked
to a couple of guys Dan is their word
about their guys getting their grades
you know these kids all have to still
take their classes and they're doing it
in you know off the computers at home
where sometimes the Wi-Fi is substandard
and so forth so to make sure that
everybody's getting what they need
academically is one of the biggest
concerns for the coaches right now
making sure that they're you know we
have people on our staff to make sure
guys are going to class and getting up
in the mornings and so on and so forth
that is no longer in play
so that's one of the big concerns I
don't think they're worried about
missing spring football I know that they
are looking forward to having some sort
of mini camp maybe a two-week period
over the course of the summer when it
becomes safe to do so
and and I think everybody will be fine
as a matter of fact I think there are
some guys who would give way to spring
football over that over the course of
the regular school year anyway for a
couple of weeks in the summer when the
freshmen who are coming to join the
class are all there spring football
right now is usually with about 60
bodies and those you go through those
bodies pretty quickly if you're trying
to get much accomplished so let
everybody kind of recuperate that time
during that time and make spring ball
more of a summer a couple of weeks I
think people would buy into that in a
big way
alright we're ready for the debut the
total are ready for the Von Trapp Family
Singers do you have family there that
will help you with this oh we've got
family you want you want to introduce my
wife Susan ok wife Susan my sons are
here who are arms in the air right now
they wanted no notoriety for this in
anybody's kitchen so matter of fact
we're having people go on strike as we
speak right now then thanks for bringing
that up
but the idea is just a little levity in
the face of our team okay alright here's
River Valley's hit it young man entities
we have stranger things watching this
person
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we we missed in MDA three-pointers and
back screams I hated load management but
this is a bit extreme
no college basketball no new sister our
March Madness is watching the
politicians blow off steam
yes one manís toilet paper and a new
vaccine Oh Oh tricky song because it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's all we got for it my friend man
well done that's great great lyrics the
Vaughan new Heysel family they're fun
bonding logically hey thanks for
checking in and we appreciate it and
hope everybody is well thank you Rick my
pleasure my pleasure everybody hunker
down we'll be fine
that's Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst with quarantine